hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob and Wade say hey
hi everybody
oh hi Bob's riding a pig over there and
now he's always oh we got some sort of
the pigs we got some weird teleport
mechanics going on but that's cool cause
it's gonna make more interesting okay
you see this giant pyramid everybody see
um piggy
there is a giant pyramid here and a
bunch of piggies here we've got all got
carrots on sticks and if you see right
at the top there there's some red cotton
that we all want cuz it's the most
valuable thing in this entire map at the
moment and we gotta take that and then
take it over to these platforms Bob is
the red one maybe ah I want the red one
yeah okay Bob's a red one he gets to
pick as he was doing winner in the last
one uh ways the white one advantage and
I'm the wood one
yeah that's Bob the only advantage so we
have to take our carrots on the sticks
and we have to ride them up to the top
of the pyramid race I go go go go we're
going time go we have 20 minutes to get
these damn things up at the top of the
mountain you guys you guys coming along
yeah you guys going I don't want to play
go piggy go Wow
get on my wave picture go peg I go and
as you can see there are things headed
towards me at the moment in this does
not look good
Oh dodge it dodging piggy there's no
that's water
ha ha ha I have to get there quick
enough before that zombie no let it out
ha ha ha Bobby you're invisible is not
working I could see you play Tuesday or
ahead of me hariya [ __ ] you can't stop
me I'm too Brown zombie juice this
morning bubbles thing ha ha ha and I got
one and you can only get one cotton at a
time but for some reason I have to so I
need to cast one off into oblivion
Oh No my carrot went away forever where
did it go away forever
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I found that to be
my gosh
exposed to get up here oh yeah I was
trying to get there and zombie was like
trying his damndest to get me to fall
down but I was to purl what so what
happens when I pick ties hahahahaha run
back down and get another oh oh yeah
I made it go to the damn platform Peggy
what the hell are you doing hey there we
go thank you thank you so awesome that
worked out so great now hahahaha
too bad argh oh mighty steed one I got
oh yeah I got it fight how you back off
oh hey back off me and my piggie we're
going back up the mountain
Peggy turn around I've got no way of
fighting anybody down all your armor
I'll give it to you I'm kind of stuck
zombies putting lava all around
yeah why instant kills pigs I don't know
this is not good this this is the worst
idea ever
dead pig of all I love avoiding Bob the
rest of the day hi Bob
Bob you shoot at mark Bob Bob how about
a fast
oh um peg I hope your son of a [ __ ]
killed my Pig that's the idea
suffocating oh oh it's so beautiful
how the hell are we gonna the zombie
you've made this quite impossible
I do believe hey Bobby stay away you Joe
ever me Bobby in miracles
I believe in miracles but from trying
today how the hell were the worst
I think that's it yeah we're all trying
to do and now I believe in miracle good
for block wide cavern of lava ha ha it's
not gonna go well I'm uh I'm a straight
line piggy this is impossible there's
water covering both sides this it can't
be done this is impossible
my pig just walked in the wall no one
cares
ah I heard the water yeah okay I'm out
Wow oh you almost helped me there Oh
your most oh no I you come on where's
idea ever
nah [ __ ] I made through oh oh stop by
the way I'm drinking England now oh yeah
I'm on my fourth of Captain Morgan
showstopper that is good I think I'm
gonna win this contest
both 101 block I have ones Oh
did anyone see what just happened no but
I heard it
fried harvest wool and I got my ax out
and knocked myself off the mountain ha
ha ha
how do you have that back but how'd you
knock yourself floating bucket of water
near me I hit my Pig it and my Pig flew
with me off of the mountain oh oh I just
thought to myself - what could possibly
go wrong I think I think we can use the
blocks of stone that the lava has
solidified into to get across rivers if
I can just finish it just
right that I'm in now it's just it just
water it's just water huh I almost made
it okay
trying again Pig go one direction do not
Pig so walk right into the water very
topic what are you doing Pig go this way
alright come on Pig you can do it love
him that's a bad as TNT why is there TNT
TD not fair
zombie it's no Strama haha oh very nice
pops out very clever bomb very Clara
oh when you hit your pig it runs in
random directions that is just
oh I'm not helpful you're big that
hasn't with an axe that has not back oh
come on Pig you're so close you're so
close zombie pig pig zombie walk pig pig
no no go to the hall now knows coming is
very good Oh forgive me hey ha ha ha ha
I mean I'm in the hole on from a stone
obsidian I don't know this is the worst
game ever
well it would be better if it wasn't
impossible
oh-oh-oh-oh pinks ha ha Oh like this so
much better shut up Wade lot of pics are
gone at the bottom what the [ __ ] I can't
even get up like a 2 inch bit of water
here I got let me try this pig piggy
turn hi peg I owe pana movin crews I
froze - Oh super scratch oh oh oh no I
moved wait a minute I'm up the mountain
I'm good I'm I'm going up the mountain
no yeah I'm halfway up already how did
this happen I don't know but my carrot
stick like went completely empty almost
a little freezing time I see Marty NT
being mysteriously placed up mountain
somebody destroyed my wall that I just
placed on the white ha ha ha who's
sabotaged me
Oh No oh my god we got like 11 minutes
from 30 seconds to declare way to use
your HK tool to find out who sabotaged
me I just placed my land I just got know
that water is not good placement for the
record the Auto God all God ha ha ha ha
ha ha stay there piggy hey God Oh mark
got it go piggy go go don't touch what I
just placed my second red wool somebody
stole one of mine how did you place -
it's definitely not that one that's on
mine how in the world did you get to
already
that's impossible is smart no you
weren't that's impossible
zombie check the logs I wasn't doing
that - that does not make me whole
you're always put to get one at a time
did you do that hit one of the time I
just got the second one came down the
mountain and found my first one was gone
oh thanks oh and that's TNT hey I don't
think something from fishy going on
there yeah so was still if I walk well
well it wasn't me Oh Pig no going the
way I'm telling you to go so much water
taeho Oh No TNT not a good spot for you
Oh down the mountain through my pig's
head oh my god your microphone or Skype
is like destroying your voice is it
better yet yes it's just fine
no why I don't have anything don't hit
me don't hit me mark come here I'm doo
doo doo bark hit that water or they're
dead water I'll tell you this sabotage
there what how so
Oh dan t know how oh no there's a hole
no thank you water Chuck piggy oh yeah
bro navigation sorry what I just
navigated a rock the edge of a whole
urge but pay just died Oh sucks this is
the worst hey do you think there's any
cotton inside the pyramid ooh
wasn't it lava it's not anymore what is
this I'm already in there zombies
hahaha this doesn't help at all
this helps even less than I thought it
was gonna be what hang on there's
something in here there's something in
here am I being attacked by a pumpkin
with a sword I don't know I want to look
but I don't want my pig to walk in that
direction oh oh boy by the way there's
definitely a lot of pumpkins with swords
with them and that is a lot of TNT
why oh no what the hell is happening
there are explosions happening in here
you suffocated in a wall I don't know
what just happened
Oh Bob's gone yeah Bob died it's gone
hahaha oh good right here did you lose
your axe no Lumpkins
rubber River Oh what the hell are these
things they're custom mobs made by the
same douchebag that is bombing us in the
[ __ ] area zombie anything about the guy
I read this has he been but not bombing
you at all I've been bug eyes I walk
right at TNT Wow why Bob what did I do
to you my poor piggy and now there's
zombies everywhere this is not a creeper
this is just wonderful isn't wonderful
I'm there are monsters everywhere oh
that song is not welcome here anymore
hmm
okay all right so who's winning I wonder
who's whoa someone keeps stealing my
line I wonder who's winning no one stole
your well I wonder who's winning Bob you
see who's winning yeah who is it looks
like it's mark hey ask me like - a
minute ago how the hell do for now
uh-huh uh-huh he's ignoring the rule
about only getting one at a time ha ha
ha ha ha ha I went inside the mountain
and there was plenty who was the last
home I get one at a time ha ha ha ha ha
I did yeah totally one at a time
wanna I know so much they ruled off stop
me huh why stop me no no I was so close
at least Bob's dying too so that's good
oh [ __ ] oh my god hi Bob I were slowly
going down the mountain in my pig
whose idea for a game was this by the
way I think your douchebag Wade can we
blame it on Wade oh yes please what you
think is my deewaar welcome Latin God
now I can't anyway yeah I know better
than to toggle lose now what did I do
besides cheap I didn't know that you
just got off yeah I'm stuck in water I
no threat to anyone that's troll in the
entire world
I know this from the regular server I
can only imagine what's going to happen
now but what more can happen that
there's nowhere to go up the whole thing
is destroyed yeah that's what we think
but we're stupid Oh zombies one crazy
guy with crazy ideas Latins like an army
of them I thought she is it rolling okay
you think she's trolling but she's not
come on take god wait I can't believe
you're not picking up on my Walking Dead
references I was but I got killed you
think you you think you're dead but
you're not you lost the who Muir oh wait
Nikki respect ha ha ha [ __ ] goddamn
pumpkin [ __ ] that's why you're not
fit to lead the group which one I've
I've both I'm walking right into TNT but
I'm doing good huh you're not fit to
leave I think ten tears oh I'm talking
like Worf - now you're just some kind of
like a drunk worse - shut up Worf - is
there a drunk
he's just pumpkin with a huh I got
another one
hi who's hitting me up here why is
everybody well
don't us both be a crater up here
creeper no creeping hahahaha
we got four minutes left
hi you back off you wait Pig
you hit my Pig I'll have kids going
crazy you show my best way I'll go
ah ah so it's Ladin done anything yet
she killed wait how wait how did you die
I don't know speak up why you're so my
spider hit no uh waitress no [ __ ]
fire don't base touch I do whoa my Pig
just start going way faster yeah my Pig
just felt like crazy
ha ha ha ha well that's ah that's good
that's good I guess
oh now my piggish flow again oh [ __ ]
there's no way to go up this way what
which Oh which way not the way where I
am that doesn't help me at all
I've got a one block path and I made it
we got three minutes loves to beat
height I see you with that bucket you
know gone kill Worf sash war SAS has
been riding pigs since the nineteen
eighties ah yeah yeah yeah listen to the
carrot was very disturbing Oh God ah ah
ha you shall go either pig observer
[ __ ] I'm stuck I'm stuck pig no oh no
why am I so getting in the wall again
haha can't seem to get oh ah oh
doh I've stuck downstairs again Oh No
where did all the lava go down here
that's like nothing left I don't know
what the belch oh no most don't belong
where my ex go oh there's my hello why
don't you axe it could just punch you oh
I love me
one man 30 second left and I'm [ __ ] a
freakin water shut that's all you know
come in here we always sing the goofy
goober song right Bob
oh my colors and what I'm doing right
now
I wanted water I want to know what's
happening now I don't know either
all I know is bad things are happening
up on that mount one minute left
I'm just gonna go fishing in the
freaking water here because I ran out of
carrot and all I've got is a fishing rod
oh [ __ ] oh I know where it is okay how
much time do we have left we have 45
seconds left
oh can you slow it down at all wait no
suddenly time has stopped that's so
strange how did that happen time is
suddenly so frozen right back up again
now we only have three seconds left no
it's just start No Oh 47 are you those
explosions I'm hearing so much about
yeah did you guys see my exit from the
inside no what happened what's it like
to show y'all involved like look at Bob
you've got uh
20 seconds why look whoa where'd this
woke up from that's my wall ha ha ha
I can't even hit you what's going on
right legitimately and got only like one
ha ha ha shut up you're talking guys who
did not time time time time time through
legitimately hard
cities came from time count him up I
have a legitimate I have eleven he's
such a real man wait [ __ ] I have eleven
oh how did I cheat how how did I just
turn into the mountain you if you broke
your own rule I never said you couldn't
go into the mound and take multiple [ __ ]
I didn't yeah you had to go to the top
of the hell okay Bob still ey
again well you're lucky the winner is
not determined by who actually won so
zombie pass judgment on this horrible
amalgamation of a game look at the
mountain with all the holes
this was quite literally the worst game
we've ever played and I loved every
minute of it so Oh
who was that I did pretty good okay yeah
ah you're just seen how know you should
seen how I was dodging the water like a
boss I was doing an amazing job dodging
all the water you guys did not even see
what was going on in my point of view
stop post Anakin's well you could think
that all you want twice but me that's
not cool well it's lucky we're gonna
play a six game next time around so who
knows anyway so that's all for now I
once I get to do my outro Wade has a
YouTube channel all that jazz link is in
the description below please check it
out for untold amounts of Settlers of
Catan like literally it's like a thirty
five part series he just does it I've
seen it it's just like up need to try it
some wool oh hope I get it no I thought
my dice rolls I'm not getting that 11 i
just prefer my dice rolls suck buttocks
buttocks how AB buttocks ah but uh a
buttocks a Botox okay so yeah and Bob
has a Twitter account and he's much more
entertaining on Twitter than I will ever
be so follow him link is in the
description below you can see all sorts
of stuff that you would like to see
there and I have YouTube channel which
you're watching this on so if you didn't
know that that's pretty sad for you so
really that's where this is going
yep yep yep so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for videos
in I've done and as always we will see
you
ah
love
ah wah